[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
are very careful
yeah we gotta clap more
so we were talking a little bit uh after
the show yesterday and we were talking
about like signs that you can tell when
your friends or your like a couple that
you know are maybe about to break up
damn i actually had this talk with my
dad
um so this is fresh
hot off the [ __ ]
press
but my dad he sat me down uh
last week and we just been having like
more father-son talks this fool told me
he's like you know i've been thinking
i'm alone right
i'm old
and he's like i don't want to beef with
your mom forever
and i was like oh [ __ ]
she goes i wanna beat your mom forever
she's alone
no point in having all this hate you
know what i mean
and i was like dad
you and mom don't belong together
we already tried it yeah and she's like
what what do you mean whatever and i was
like based off of your guys is like core
personalities so this even goes i think
even before the relationship but really
understanding who you are and the other
person is i'm like your core personality
don't fit like you
you like to grab life by the horns and
control your own destiny right you're
like this [ __ ] happens i'm gonna move
like i'm gonna do what a nice thing to
say yeah right that's what my that's
what my dad does that's cool my mom is
literally like
tell me my future please i'll do it
anything you want me so i'm like that
core trait if someone is uh i'm gonna do
some [ __ ] myself the other person is
always putting my confidence in someone
else like you guys don't i always tell
them like you guys shouldn't even have
got together i should have never even
been born but you're not even looking at
it the right way okay okay they're
sexist that's where you're wrong no no
no obviously
look at the [ __ ] classic
whatever that is that they made that was
a jizz product that came out if i'm
[ __ ] human that was a jizz problem
he already loves her right he's kind of
like saying i [ __ ] still love her in
his own way right
he's still [ __ ] making you know but
and bart shut him down
and you don't want them to [ __ ] deal
with you and bother you let them [ __ ]
annoy each other that they're gonna
bother him that's the thing exactly
you're gonna bring him in as an
intermediary that's exactly that's why i
told my dad i'm like he's like wha what
could possibly go wrong oh everything
everything possibly be at the end of the
day
mom's a chick right
that is a good point that's a good
observation
they [ __ ] complain [ __ ] i'm
like you think she's gonna complain to
you nope she's gonna complain to me yeah
so now it's gonna be this [ __ ]
three-way relationship where you [ __ ]
piss her off
she doesn't know she doesn't you don't
know what she's complaining about
because she ain't gonna talk to your ass
because you haven't talked to you for
like three decades yeah your mom
wouldn't complain to your dad three
decades bro no cause she's closer to me
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] she texts me
she texts me for a reason so when he
just did something wrong in the past she
wouldn't even like call him out on
she'll just hit you up she probably go i
already knew because of [ __ ] destiny
[Laughter]
says
that your dad's gonna piss me my husband
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] hey what if your
dad like cons a system and like pays a
fortune teller to tell your mom that's
like yo like you gotta spend the rest of
your life with this man that's kind of
sweet it doesn't work it's romantic mom
got like six of those homies that's what
i'm saying he got it like [ __ ] grease
all six maybe that's a lot that's
probably cheap honestly
no not until they know that everybody
they're all competing for
that they're all in on a racket together
i'm thinking of the fortune tellers with
the bars on the window and the neon sign
and [ __ ] oh i do it for two hundo my mom
has a full jk news cast of fortune
teller homies but she could probably
have her own destiny just kidding
destiny just kidding
just kidding fortune
just kidding fortune
[Music]
that's so funny i would watch the [ __ ]
out of that i'd rather watch that show
in this show
yo can you just bring your entire mom's
homies in for like and they can do the
hot seat for us they could tell us our
fortune you know we should get a fortune
telling you what is this i'm actually
down to bring my mom on and we could ask
her put her on the hot seat yeah that'd
be sick oh that'd be so good dude we
should put her on a mattress
because bart [ __ ] spent the first 12
years of his life
we'll put bart next door on the mattress
and we'll [ __ ] interview i'll be way
too scared if your mom was saying i
wouldn't even know how to ask questions
i would shut the [ __ ] up i feel like i'm
scared of your mom based on the stories
you tell about you your dad would be
different i feel like your dad is here
to be different but if it's your mom i'm
gonna shut the [ __ ] up they're actually
the complete opposite so my mom like if
you meet her she's like super bubbly and
charismatic and nice right she's like
this and then oh she's so friendly your
guard's down and then she [ __ ] seeps
her [ __ ] fangs into you she's
controlling you like a puppy you don't
even know my dad is like a grumpy asian
man this guy's kind of mean but then
he's like offering you soup every day
and all that stuff
this guy's actually really nice on the
inside
that's what i'm saying they shouldn't
have been together dude i think
opposites attract though perfect
or they're perfect that's such bad i
think opposites attract but there's
there's definitely got to be like some
very minimum core basics that they both
share that are that will make them
compatible but opposites attract i think
because you know i don't know dating
someone that's like exactly like you was
like super boring yeah were there signs
that your parents were about to break up
like that you right out of my mouth
i mean i was sick so i didn't i didn't
know i was sick i was so small wow not
what i wanted to hear not what i wanted
to hear yeah yeah wow how many breakups
have you guys had
is that what how many breakups how many
breakups oh god i mean so [ __ ] many
you know
the fact that you said it behind your
mouth like this like so [ __ ] man i
can't even count man
no we're like my fault no we're like her
fault
and do we count the relationships from
junior high on i need to can i i need to
pad my numbers nothing nothing under six
months
okay uh i'm out right
i'm out or is there a relationship where
like you guys got together and like even
in the first part of it there were some
signs that you're like oh this probably
wouldn't work but like you know i'm
gonna try to overlook it or try to work
it out and then eventually that those
are the exact same reasons why you guys
broke up
i don't know what your question was i
don't either wait i don't get wait can
you clarify what do you mean because so
for
my dad right like
if my dad's a very logical person from
off the bat she he knows that my mom
doesn't operate on lodge like when you
have a poor trait it seeps into
everything how you order food how you
put clothes on everything right but then
you're so infatuated that you just kind
of overlook it you're like
yeah i think that was all my
relationships yeah and then just all of
them so all of them you have red red
flags and they're like oh this could
work because i think ultimately i'm i'm
probably leaning more toward an optimist
so like when i'm in a relationship i
always feel like anything can be solved
yeah so even if there are red flags i'm
like that can be solved
and then get to i'll get around to it
yeah yeah well we'll eventually solve
it's like an eventual chore that is what
you're saying right i'll kick it out of
her system it's on the list
[Laughter]
from your experience physically
physically from her is that how you
handle it though are you gonna kick her
are you like i'll i'll deal with it
later because i'm too much enjoying the
present with this person
yeah i mean like it's not that big of a
deal i feel like maybe i can deal like
maybe i need to learn something yeah
it's like is that a red flag is it like
a yellow flag
yeah yeah that's true yeah that's true
really fast we can go through it we can
speed through it that's true
yeah is it a pet peeve of mine or is it
something that i need to work on because
i'm like maybe i'm just annoyed because
eh maybe it's just my thing you know i
don't know
i like the [ __ ] it's too good to resist
there it is
[Laughter]
depth depth depth [ __ ]
i remember i remember i'll tell you a
story i was i moved to la with this girl
and we were we're doing improv together
and [ __ ] and i remember
weird this stupid [ __ ] with improv right
so the short form improv right which is
like the who's lines and anyway stuff
and it's like two to five minutes of
scene max and then there's long form
improv which is like the herald it's
like all this other stuff right who
cares
but when we moved to la
we were the idea was to stop doing short
form improv which just seems kind of
hacky in the community and start doing
long-form improv but then she comes she
tries out for comedy sports la which was
like
you know it's like a
big company right and so you go work
there but you're doing short form improv
and i was definitely i didn't even try
out for it but i was [ __ ]
pissed about it because i was like we
moved here to do long form improv why
the [ __ ] are you doing this hacky ass
[ __ ] right i'm just being a [ __ ]
stupid 22 year old kid like basically
being insecure that she got into this
theater company and i was maybe jeff i
think i was just jealous jealous
jealousy jealous steve and then i i
wasn't
being supportive of her having done that
i was being the opposite it's
discouraging which is which was you know
definitely an immature jealous stupid
thing but i think that was a big sign
that we were headed towards breakup zone
is not having her back
being very like
like petty and stupid about something so
that was more on you and you recognized
definitely not it was all on me it was
all on me i don't blame her at all
because we ended up we ended up breaking
up and she ended up dumping me right and
i think that that's something i look
back on and i go oh man i definitely was
just being jealous of a [ __ ]
and but i didn't know how to
articulate it articulate that and i
don't think i was being honest with
myself about what the true thing was
behind it today's video is brought to
you by babble
so right now i've been missing some
international travel
and um back in last july me and hannah
went to mexico right so for our
anniversary i took her to a mexican
fair
concert flash like slash outside bazaar
slash shopping place food fair it was
pretty amazing right and we were there
and i feel like we were the only
non-hispanic
and we stuck out like a sore thumb but
everyone was super nice they were just
like oh cool you want to try this
whatever
and i really missed speaking spanish but
i didn't want to be super like offensive
but thanks to babel i was able to look
it up real quick and get myself brushed
up on all the stuff and be like okay i
feel confident again let me experiment
on using spanish with my fellow espanols
over here
yeah and then what happened it'll work
they're like i speak english fools
i use babbles to learn english
but no there was it was pretty cool
because like
you know they knew that i was just
trying to practice and stuff and so
they're super supportive but that's what
i really like about babel is they have
so many different languages that you can
learn from what's really cool is they do
it in these real quick 10-minute lessons
yeah they're really quick and because
they're so easy to digest you can start
speaking and having conversations like
in real life like not those crazy like
super official words but actual
conversational vocabulary words in less
than three weeks and it was created by
over 150 language experts yeah and they
even have speech recognition technology
so it can help you correct your
enunciations you can pronounce things
better and better and better and you can
choose from 14 different languages like
spanish italian french german
all kinds of languages right now you can
save up to 60 off your subscription yeah
when you go to babble.com off the record
that's babble.com
off the record for up to 60 off your
subscription babble language for life
essay i was being the stupid petty [ __ ]
who's just going didn't we not move here
for the long haul improv what the [ __ ]
we're supposed to be doing ucb and all
[ __ ] and and then she's like getting
distracted when you're doing ucb how
stupid is this by the way it's really
dumb you know your relationship is
long-form improv
[Laughter]
as a herald i don't know what that means
we'll bring that back later okay gotcha
which is the joker especially after he
said nobody cares when he said that
that it is it's such a minor detail but
that is the weird
core that i built around that stupid
excuse because it meant so much to you
at the time it did it did and it's super
hard to see that at the time yeah but
when you're in the situation like you're
like kind of like what he's saying it's
like there is a logic to what you're
saying yeah if you were to take out the
insecurity and the emotion bubble a lot
like there's logic to that yeah like
moving there to try and do something and
pursue a certain way especially after
having gone through it but then when it
doesn't happen you're like what the [ __ ]
but obviously you're right now in
retrospect but it's so hard to see that
like it is you said you were 20 when
that happened yeah yeah dude baby
i think a red flag is when they
start looking at you in a negative light
so
when they start making comments putting
you down things like that that are like
even in a jokingly way or like it's very
small and then they start picking at
things
and and wanting to change you yeah when
they mean it that's bad not breaking
your balls no no like i mean i'm not
saying they're like some red flags
divorce
i need to
i need to get out of here guys
yeah we love getting our balls for sure
it's [ __ ] hilarious right because
we're we're in that environment all the
time but then when it goes
down to like they're serious about hey
you should be wearing this you should be
doing this you should be doing this for
your career and it's like are you my
[ __ ] mom what the [ __ ]
it's like what's going on and then
i think they're dissatisfied with you as
a human being they don't like you for
you they're trying to change you into
someone they want you to be and i think
that's like the beginning stages of like
get the [ __ ] out of there
that could also be a reflection of where
they're dissatisfied with their own
lives too right that's why they're
taking it out on you instead of
rejecting it yeah yeah or establish
boundaries i'd say just pulling the
ripcord on that is is a little maybe
extreme
yeah what do you mean oh just if they're
like hey
you want to like start i want to start
you know giving you ideas of what you
should wear and stuff if you're like hey
i like what i wear actually
boundaries because it comes up it
becomes well then it becomes like a like
a i never want to change anything about
my life which is also damaging i think
because it's like because i've
like dating different people you learn
different uh things that like that they
bring to the table they're like oh i
didn't think about it that way or
whatever but if i or like different you
know view how they view the world stuff
like that perspective and if you just
say oh i don't want to change any way in
the way that i think dress or wear or
anything like that then you kind of cut
yourself off to a lot of like growth you
know for the future so i think that like
yeah within reason like if they're if
you feel like it's just them only
focusing on the negative about you then
obviously there's a red flag there but i
definitely think that especially if
someone cares for you then they're gonna
bring things up in a way that they're uh
looking to like maybe help you out you
know in certain ways the delivery that
matters a lot and also the frequency and
like you know where that's coming from
if it's coming from a place of
resentment or if it's coming from a
place of like oh i want you know help
you improve i really want to help you
versus i'm just [ __ ] talking [ __ ]
yeah cause like nagging
nagging and constructive criticism is a
very fine line yeah and it can be
blurred really easily depending on who's
giving and one is louder than the other
yeah
[Laughter]
and one's more consistent yeah what
happens all the [ __ ] time
even in my text messages
hypothetically yeah yeah yeah in this
scenario like you forgot to all caps
what you just said
i know the true volume of it
your bigger passive aggressive
[Laughter]
this might be like a dub but like in
answering that question like signs that
a couple like breaking up you guys uh
have that friend who like
you're always asking how they're doing
and stuff like that and they're like i
swear it's like years of like fights or
arguments but they're sitting together
yeah you know what i mean
we're like you and your homies sometimes
you're not trying to be dick but you're
like maybe this is just pretty
what i'm talking about but it just goes
forever every single time you ask this
homie like yo i had a friend like that i
was just like i would every time i would
see him i was like hey do you regret the
girlfriend
where everyone's rooting for them to
split because it was like like super
unhealthy
are you cool with the chick too though
mm-hmm were you cool with your friend's
girlfriend too yeah yeah yeah i met her
first actually oh wow but you were
rooting for both of them to split they
just were super like unhealthy every
time i would talk to either of them
because they were both my friends they
were just like complaining about the
other person i was like bro this is like
this is not healthy like you all are
told for this like you should break up
yeah yeah but they just both didn't want
to do it because they're both really
comfortable which i guess that's the
worst yeah i've seen a lot of that [ __ ]
because yeah it's scarier right it's
scary to like leave something that's
comfortable and then you're also as like
a third party friend too like especially
because like um i i
have some of those friends where i'm
also like homies at long time friends
with like their significant others so
you're in the middle and you're like
i care about everybody
so my literal best thing to do is to not
have an opinion yeah yeah you don't have
to sit down stay out of it yeah you know
otherwise like to do this you're doing
this or to do this you're doing this and
it's kind of like that's not the [ __ ]
point the point is just be like how can
i be a support circle when somebody's
having a hard time other than that i'm
like it's not my [ __ ] business but
they were both like we should break up
with each other and so then whatever
they both agreed was like you should you
should do that just like why don't you
do that yeah they were telling you
separately yeah yeah are they still
together or they're married no [ __ ] no
they're like
they they broke up and i was like good
for them i had to be extremely honest
with a friend with with two friends um a
couple years ago because
they were um i was like it was like a
group setting right a bunch of people
there and then um this one chick friend
of mine was asking for advice about this
dude that she's dating and i was like oh
yeah yeah he's a good dude oh [ __ ] and
then um
this couple was like whoa what do you
think about our relationship and i was
like you don't want to know what i think
about yourself
i just told them that straight up
because i had and what was their face
when they when you said that sank a
little bit but
honestly it was just because i had
mediated and stuff for them so many
goddamn [ __ ] times
that i was like i am not doing this but
yeah if they know that
they're just like looking for weird
validation like no i was like boundary
set it in your face it's your boundary
right there i mean like outside looking
in if i've seen relationships where
both are like talking so much [ __ ]
[ __ ] about the other the most [ __ ] ever
with a megaphone
and everyone's just like why you still
in there and they're still together and
then i'm just like
why that's just their love language ooh
talking [ __ ] [ __ ] talking yeah do you
actually believe that that some people
are so toxic that they should just be
toxic soul mates maybe because it's not
necessarily like you belong together but
maybe it's like you don't belong with
anybody else who's not toxic so be
together oh
i never thought of it that way it's more
just to keep the nuclear radiation away
from the general population yeah you
know what i mean it's kind of like
you're talking about you
whether you belong together it doesn't
matter we should weld them
get a welding crew in there
as long as they're happy toxic people
deserve happiness dude
i've heard such quotes as he is a lying
piece of [ __ ] i will never trust him
again and then like the next week
they're like yeah we're fine
they figured it out
i don't want to die
so does that mean those aren't red flags
if they're still together no they're red
flags because they're just not normal
people
they're just not normal human beings
they're red flags for everybody else's
yeah well so yeah some flags are so red
they're beyond the couple you know what
i mean it's so red that the platonic
friends are like oh my goodness they
could even see but the real question
they shouldn't be able to see it the
real question is for those couples that
you could think of that are like very
toxic in their minds they probably don't
think that they are at all of course not
for for a temporary amount of time
they're actually going to deal with
their real situation like their their
long-term [ __ ] up relationship they're
actually going to deal with it and then
they're going to smooth it over and go
now we were fine everything's fine yeah
yeah yeah we're tripping until the next
detonation
it's that post not clarity where you're
like oh we need to fix this until like
an hour passes post not clarity hits you
so hard too it's it's a crazy force man
sex of passion posting that clarity
you're like dude i'll never trust you
yeah
do you ever look at the the whole day
leading up to the post-net clarity and
being like jesus i was jumping through
[ __ ] hoops man
these hoops are on [ __ ] fire dude
like holy [ __ ] sometimes posting clarity
is like
wow i just watched bambi getting [ __ ]
by a monster wait wait what
my man you're watching the same porn as
i am
oh yeah
i'm trying to figure out if that was
like you like like describing yourself
talking about bambi the cartoon bambi
getting [ __ ] by a scary monster
that monster named steve green sometimes
you're like
yeah this is really really hot bookmark
afterwards you're like
i hate my visual images really [ __ ] up
you liked it until you tried it you know
what i mean i'm like why did why what a
thumper have to do with any of that
that's in the name bro
i haven't seen bambi in like [ __ ] 25
years can you tell
[Music]
you